Good morning children
Good morning papa
how are you today
good papa
good i'm glad to hear it because today i
have something very special planned for you
eleven you're listening
Welcome back everyone hello are you listening
stranger things just dropped a new season 4
teaser trailer so there's a bunch of easter eggs
here as usual it's pretty cryptic with a lot of
references to things from earlier in the series
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel of course i'll be doing videos
for stranger things season 4 when it gets here
be sure to subscribe to get everything this one
is all about Eleven and her powers coming back and
her just flashing back remembering things from the
hawkins laboratory where papa dr brenner matthew
modine's character was testing all the children
in her program until she tore a hole in their
dimension opening the rift to the upside down
you also probably spotted the teaser says two
of four the last trailer that they released with
hopper being revealed alive in siberia russia says
one of four he was on that chain gang after the
events of the season 3 post-credits scene where
they revealed the russian prison with their own
white demogorgon that they were just using like
a glorified trash compactor eating prisoners
that they wanted to punish or get rid of so i'll
talk about what that naming scheme means but just
starting at the beginning of the new footage all
this footage is meant to take place in the past
probably in Eleven's memories like a flashback or
a hallucination or a nightmare and it starts
on the clock in her classroom there from the
hawkins lab that reads 3 p.m i think the three is
just a reference to the next teaser trailer like
this one says two of four in the stranger
things bio and in the video description
and they probably just want to let you know that
there will be a third and a fourth teaser trailer
the fourth one is probably when they're gonna
drop an official season 4 really big trailer
in the official release date which normally i
would have said would be this fall just based on
when they're filming right now but just recently
galen matazaro who plays dusty on the show
recently claimed that they have a long ways to
go before they're done filming season 4 episodes
so that's why you may have seen talk recently
about season 4 possibly being delayed till next
year in 2022. if that happens they'll probably
release it in spring next year just because it's
a big period for dropping huge series and maybe
wait till like late march or april so the four in
the naming scheme here like the one four two four
maybe three four in the next teaser trailer and
then four four in the last teaser trailer those
could also be references to season four coming out
in april 2022. like in the naming scheme here with
the teasers the four could represent season four
but it could also represent the month for april of
the year i don't think it'll take him that long to
actually finish all the season four episodes but
what might wind up happening is they just finish
filming and then sit on the footage like put it on
a shelf until april next year netflix is known for
doing that just sitting on episodes and waiting to
release them for a long time it's called putting
things in netflix jail but then they show you
the camera system that they had installed in the
lab watching the children everywhere they went
observing them just to see what kind of powers
they might manifest or weird behavior they
exhibit but in the next scene they show you
children playing with cars on the rainbow design
here on the floor because Eleven is probably just
flashing back and this is taking place in her
memory also you notice on the floor here this
car that the child on the right is playing with
is a bronco that looks just like hopper's car
the car that the other child is playing with the
van looks like the van from season one the white
and blue van of the two people from hawkins lab
that were chasing after eleven trying to recapture
her and bring her back then there's another child
playing with this giant plinko game that they
intercut with all the rest of the trailer footage
you see the separate children playing with the
chess game the chessboard and a couple other items
here the chessboard i think is just a reference to
the games that the kids on the show play like the
dungeons and dragons games just other games that
they play together i think it's also meant to be a
very obvious white versus black metaphor for good
versus evil like Eleven versus the mind flayer
both of them playing this chess game against
each other remember the mind flayer is still alive
in the upside down they only defeated its avatar
all the rats all the people that it absorbed into
this golem that was controlling psychically from
the upside down you see that plinko piece slowly
going towards the bottom but then they jumped
to the magic eight ball that they were playing
with in mike's basement all signs point to yes
the group was using the magic eight ball in the
show previously just because it was a big thing
during the 80s and the show is all about 80s
nostalgia and pop culture and there's a certain
level of mysticism that they bake into everything
consulting the ethers like it's actual magic that
powers the eight ball like mixing the fantasy
sci-fi tropes of the dungeons and dragons game the
idea of actual magic with eleven's powers the mind
flayer the multiverse with the upside down other
dimensions then you see another child building
a tower of red bricks then you see the plinko
piece finally reached the bottom falling into the
seventh slot there's the three five and six that
are exposed and the pieces are in the four seven
and eight spots so everyone's like what do these
numbers mean what are they trying to tell us here
they've been hyping up the number four so much in
the last two trailers they've released so i think
this is also just meant to be another reminder
that there will be a third teaser like the number
three is exposed number three teaser trailer later
this year then there's a wide shot of the whole
room with all the kids and then dr brenner matthew
modine's character out of the hallway walking down
the hallway passed all the doors to the kids rooms
into that same classroom he says good morning
children and you hear Eleven's heavy breathing
sounds sort of intercut with this making it extra
creepy he greets all the children then they greet
him saying good morning papa the account for
stranger things was also tweeting papa a lot too
mostly because dr brenner papa is so integral
to the idea of what's happening in this teaser
trailer but this is actually meant to be him
matthew modine is coming back for new season 4
episodes he was spotted on set filming episodes i
don't know how many he's going to be in but it'll
probably be a similar situation to what we saw
of him during season 2 where she's hallucinating
him remembering him it's not him actually coming
back to life this is all phantoms and nightmares
that she's having he says how are you today as
the camera continues to pan around to the door
to eleven's room then he says he has something
very special planned for you today in follows
with eleven are you listening which is what they
named this whole second teaser trailer video as
eleven's eyes open but it's the younger version
of eleven with the shaved head back in hawkins lab
the very special thing that he's talking about
in the context of this flashback scene when
this is meant to be happening would have been
the special test of their powers like this is
Eleven remembering the events that led up to her
tearing the rift open to the upside down but in
present day as she's having these nightmares these
flashbacks it's also a reference to Eleven getting
her powers back in present day like remember at
the end of season three she seemingly lost her
abilities when they were able to kill the mind
flayer's puppet and hopper seemingly died they
seemingly closed the rift to the upside down but
all these moments that she's thinking about the
hawkins lab this is her just dealing with her
trauma continuing to deal with her trauma also
the fresher trauma of losing hopper still thinking
that he's dead but i also think the idea of Eleven
are you listening that dialogue is her
getting her powers back in listening
hearing hopper on the other side of the world
because she would be powerful enough to do that
eventually hopper has to be reunited with the
group he has to be involved in the plot somehow
the only way that the kids would be able to find
out that hopper was still alive would be if he
was somehow able to contact them himself like send
them a physical note or a verbal message somehow
they did tease the tom Wlaschiha's character this
russian prison guard you might remember him from
game of thrones as jaqen h'ghar he showed up in
that last big trailer video on the chain gang
a little while ago they teased that his character
would be friend hopper be sort of an ally to him
on the dl and might wind up helping him somehow
while he's on chain gang here so that could also
be one of the keys to hopper escaping prison and
just warning the children about what's going on
but in the other trailer footage they were
trying to hype up the idea that we're not in
hawkins anymore like they will be leaving hawkins
for a while they kind of left at the end of season
three implying that they were going to be gone
but the funny thing about that they've actually
been filming scenes inside the hawkins sets on
the show like you actually see footage of them
at the video store this is the video store that
sadie and steve work at where you have a couple
of the kids showing up you have dusty max visiting
in what looks like a couple separate scenes like
not all these are connected to each other they
have released a couple other teasers like they
have footage of them just messing around with the
idea of the hellfire club they tease that that's
the title of the first episode and that there will
be nine episodes instead of eight episodes like
their regular art season two is another example
of them doing an extra episode the whole idea the
hellfire club you see them running here with this
flag that's probably just what they named the new
version of their club most of you big comic book
fans will be thinking about the x-men version of
the hellfire club that actually started the
1970s but was created by chris claremont and
was featured heavily during the 80s so it was a
big thing during the 1980s when these kids would
have been alive and reading actual comic books
and if you didn't see the duffer brothers we're
also talking about doing stranger things season
five so it kind of confirms that they're doing
more stories after season four but they didn't
say if that would just be more episodes like
a season five legit or if they'd be doing some
kind of stranger things movie to wrap things up
but it does sound like there will be more story
after season four but everybody let me know in
the comments if you spotted any big easter eggs
in this teaser trailer footage that i didn't talk
about in the video i will do more stranger things
videos when we get more teaser trailer footage but
leave all your big questions and your requests
in the comments below speaking of big netflix
stuff that's coming up if you're a big fan of the
witcher the witcher season 2 will be releasing
all their episodes later this year probably
in november or december i've already done a
couple videos for the last few teaser trailers
they've released so i'll put links for those
in the description too my next big series that
i'll be doing videos for will be the loki series
marvel will be dropping episodes for that in a
couple weeks you can click here for the last big
trailer for that and click here for that really
big marvel phase 4 movies trailer and the eternals
trailer footage thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!